5 si cette musique alors ma plus grosse
barre car il y en a tellement
autour et fous rires que j'ai pu avoir
avec siri c'est quand j'ai enfin vu les
fesses de jean michel maire se sont
toutes les soirées aux côtés d'isabelle
dit n'importe quoi mais elle le fait
avec talent et elle est drôle c'est à
chaque fois que je suis à côté de jean
michel maire à chaque blague de merde
qui sort je suis en fous rires la plus
grosse dark ages pense que c'était quand
on est à las vegas sur le strip et que
on a laissé isabelle en pleine solitude
tout seul dans la voiture
[Musique]
germé à moi
takacs sommet tout autour on s'est marré
vraiment c'était très beau la belge suit
pas rater j'ai eu la chance de piéger
mon père pour la grande race rats on est
on a fait croire à mon papa avec eux de
leurs moyens ma femme
il trône et elles ont été en couple
pendant la can cash est vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup ri la prochaine fois je te
croise des montes tu es mon talent à
leurs fous rires avec valérie bénaïm
pour pour les 35 heures de baba et quand
je leur dis que s'est poursuivie la nina
au départ ils mentent et de david sénat
au lieu de cela nos marques et en fait
on était tous partis dans un fou rire
absolue mais qui avait duré au moins
cinq ou dix minutes je ruisselet je
pleurais vous connaissent pas vraiment
[Rires]
le plus gros fous rires je vais dire
c'est pendant les quatre tiers il vous
appelez qu'ils connaissent à appliquer
pour passe mal au dos
j'essaie de parler à cyril sans écouter
jean michel qui est à côté de moi ça
fait une séquence très très longue très
très drôle
vous appelez qui pour passez moi l'autre
con mais ça rien
[Musique]